is Dennis Falcone still outside he's
there's a huge fan Oh Sebastian yeah
that he told me yesterday that he was a
big fan of yours and I noticed him 20
minutes ago well hi the studio door yeah
we can bring him in we can bring him in
he's a legendary DJ yeah dennis is a
legendary DJ he's previously been banned
from the show but first of all I love
that Dennis's comfort position is just
I'll just share Sebastian finding a mic
got a mic there's why it's not empty
what you're doing come over say a lot of
the guests I know I know that but you
just kind of stood though you're gonna
talk in a thin air
no you wanted to share a mic with with
Sebastian you told me yesterday you're a
huge fan right the guy's fantastic he's
one of my top three Italian comedians
well top three Italian he's kind of my
ethnicity not as funny as the blacks as
far as circumcised guys I enjoy him Sal
Richards okay Wow old-school
miss Sebastian number one wow that's
good company because I'm Italian too so
everything you were talking about that
special related to it Oh without a doubt
without it - have you seen him live no
no life good assume on TV though he did
seven shows of the beacon you couldn't
get one ticket I can go buy a ticket and
seven shows he was there around the
clock Danny likes comps do you like do
you like non-italian comedians oh yeah
there's a few good ones what do you like
what's that all right Oh Danny don't I
mean he just fantastic because
everything I'm from Brooklyn mm-hmm so
you're Chicago so it's very similar with
the Italian people did you grow up with
a medic my grandfather's name Sebastiano
mean Boston Philly the Italians are all
the same yeah were you cold to me it's
also great in my life people I call it
gravy
I think gravy I think of brown turkey
gravy I know absolutely I think of life
it's all gravy that's right by the way
all Benny's doing is pointing out
differences as he's trying
what's running down his leg watching
this special last week and my wife said
I like him he's clean he's very well him
sindbad sindbad is very clean also
Sinbad
Charlie Callas was very clean on the D
Martin show yes Sebastian do you like
that is like a compliment like oh you
know I like you because you're clean or
would you prefer to just be a comedian
okay all right it's nice because it to
be as successful as Sebastian is or a
guy like Gaffigan who is very also very
funny being clean some guys are cleaner
cornballs but then those guys were clean
who are legitimately funny it's really
hard to do right it's right to be that
good for that long without going into so
many different areas I mean that's it's
it's it's it's not easy that's what you
respect Dennis huh yeah yeah I think so
because it's tougher to be cleaned you
know I'm funny well that's a direct shot
at Jim Norton but go on nobody just
saying easy time stuff comedian I
couldn't take my wife to see Jimmy Oh
should I leave with me with anybody so I
would just say I love the guy he's funny
as hell yes not her cup of tea yeah but
you should continue relating to
Sebastian that was the same between
Chicago and Brooklyn your family members
of the IRA he was talking about his
grandmother making macaroni in in the
basement yeah we don't call it pasta
called macaroon we call the pasta show
but my grandparents used to make the
wine in the basement we did a little are
you call abrasive Cillian buddies what
are you Syrian and my mother's family's
from Napoli and you know I'm calibrating
for Cecilia okay so you have very very
little in common with nothing he's got
that gene gene
yeah so your parent came right over
my father came when he was 15 my mother
was born in the United States so we were
more Americanized than anything else but
to speak to your point my grandparents
were the type of grandparents for you
they lived in the basement they cooked
in the basement it was all about food
and real integrins yeah so do you go
back over it or no have you ever been my
father and I went back to Sicily for the
first time I've ever been in six years
and the first time he's ever gone back
in 50 just you and him yeah oh wow so we
went back to where he grew up and you
know he says it's where I played
foosball and this is where I learned how
to play soccer and I'm an emotional guy
right I'm like I take like an E it was
really and he was nothing nothing
affects just been shocked that I'm in
back in Sicily so that trip he is now
gone back every year since so I would
never get emotional go to my dad's old
neighborhood I'd be like let's get out
of here there's a lot of blacks we got
to wrap the show up for the day why you
know what this thing though of having
that chance to go back with your dad to
Sicily it's just unbelievable
after you get to kill somebody then you
jump back on the plane waiting once
though and Joe Colombo's their old
telling gangster yeah and my father told
me don't go bother him oh no I wish you
have a meal at all but we grew up in
Brooklyn where there was a lot of those
wise guys they used to work you know not
work at all I used to they used to sit
in front of the social clubs remember
John Gotti would talk about the you know
so I would see you know my mom's like
that and I would walk you know when he
was off I said dad how come these guys
don't know during the day and it would
just sit on chairs and drink and play
cards he goes you know don't bother them
don't talk it's the working man that's
the real heroes I was very similar to a
Bronx Tale
yes right HRA would they try to issue is
in Chicago right very similar would they
try to seduce you and your father go
ahead I'll talk to my daughter I'll be
back home for Thanksgiving thanks ray do
lesson my mother makes fresh sauce she
doesn't buy that ragu or anything it's
fresh stays up crazy you've got nothing
in common center sauce nothing in common
we're Italians connecting you didn't
connect that's right guys make it a
basement yeah we're done the speed
additive eel will you wrap up with the
toothpick you ever have those biddies
they call them veal rollatini the
Americans this penis Sebastian you think
you can hang out with Dennis si
Sebastian special yeah on Showtime now
available on demand it's why would you
do that it's his new special which he
shot here in New York at the Beacon